[Musique]
retourner au restaurant au musée au
cinéma ou dans les salles de sport tout
le monde en rêve et cela pourrait bien
passer par la création d'un pass
sanitaire emmanuel macron l'a évoqué
hier à l'issue d'un conseil européen
il s'agirait d'une sorte de passeport
permettant l'accès à ces lieux publics
en précisant par exemple que vous êtes
vacciné ou bien que vous avez réalisé un
test pcr négatif un récent
[Musique]
et puis cet après-midi en gala merkel la
chancelière allemande a quant à elle
annoncé l'arrivée d'un passeport
vaccinale avant l'été permettant de
circuler d'un pays à l'autre de l'union
européenne
un nouveau vaccin anti covit bientôt
mise sur le marché aux états unis un
comité d'experts un recommandé hier le
vaccin johnson & johnson il a deux
avantages
il peut être administré en une seule
dose est conservé dans un simple
réfrigérateur le feu vert final devrait
être donnée par l'agencé américaine des
médicaments la vaccination ça n'attend
pas c'est visiblement ce que s'est dit
un papy de 88 ans hier il a été flashé à
191 km heure sur une route du bas rhin
limitée à 110 le chauffard a expliqué
très naturellement au gendarme qu'il
roulait vite car ils avaient rendez vous
pour se faire vacciner
résultat il n'a plus de voiture il a
plus de permis et le paradoxe c'est
qu'il a dû rater son rendez-vous de
vaccination inédit une quarantaine de
seniors de la résidence d'arcadie
bloquent leur rue on peut pas mourir
et puis vous allez le voir à paris cet
après-midi avant 18 heures en tout cas
les quais étaient bondées 3600 policiers
sont mobilisés ce soir dans la capitale
et sa petite couronne ces 2000
confinement qui est insupportable pour
tout le monde et qui va briser des vies
des carrières etc
c'est pas pour ça que peut pas
s'empêcher justement de vivre de rire de
se moquer vous savez on voulait un
président qui ont peu puisse dire ta
grosse blind essor mais en même temps on
lui dit déjà ta gueule oui déjà
les gens lui dis ta gueule c'est surtout
des projets français peuple rebelle
moi j'ai toujours dit des fois y'a plus
d'humanité dans les yeux d'une vache ou
d'un ou de nos animaux comme les miens
dieu regarde moi trois dans les
appalaches dans les yeux de certains
maintien pareil par exemple dans les
yeux de certains docteurs qui veulent
nous confiner là je préfère regarder les
yeux d'une vache
abandonnez vous n'avez pu rouvrir entre
les deux compliments oui c'était assez
ridicule d'ailleurs parce qu on
demandait aux gens qui venaient en
couple on va dire s'amuser dans votre
club
on a c'est à dire que les chandelles
c'est d'abord la fête well donc entrer
aux chandelles la nuit pour ne pas
pouvoir danser ça pas beaucoup d'intérêt
c'est vrai les gens avaient le droit de
faire l'amour mais pas de danse est
exactement d'une tristesse absolue
clara elle m'a envoyé cinq ou six textes
il y en a deux tout de suite qu'il
mangeait sous titre je suis tout de
suite mais celle là c'est joli c'est
extra c'est le titre comme ici sur les
taxes parce que je suis sur le terrain
je n'étais pas là voilà c'est ça selon
vous ce jouet est il un homme ou une
femme est bien son fabricant vient de
trancher
c'est avant tout une pomme de terre
oubliez donc monsieur tête de patates
pour être plus inclusive la marque
américaine abandonne son attribut
masculin
désormais ce n'est plus qu'une tête de
patates il ressemble à tom cruise fait
ses cascades lui-même et à ses mimiques
mais ce n'est pas lui qui vient d'ouvrir
un compte tic toc
il s'agit d'un dip fait qu un montage
vidéo dans lequel le visage de l'acteur
a été ajoutée sur le corps d'un autre
le résultat est bluffant de réalisme et
un peu inquiétant pour l'avenir
l'auteur n'est pas un manipulateur
leconte se nomme deep tom cruise comme
un avertissement pour cette fois en tout
cas mais au bout du compte monsieur ou
madame
chacun pourra continuer à modeler sa
patate comme il le souhaite et ce qui
est sûr c'est que monsieur patate ira
toujours très bien avec madame raclette
il était là ça va aller il voyage était
en train de trembler ferme en mai soit
le moment où tes jambes elle tremble
tout seul tu peux pas les contrôler tu
devrais essayer de boire si tu connais
l'alcool non pas le fond c'est vraiment
formidable dans ces cas les faire des
conseils ou plus jamais je ne bois de
l'eau aujourd'hui aulas a fait déjà un
petit bout de temps oui mais sa femme
tient non non moi j'ai connu julien
clerc des fois pas très clair mais il ya
eu quand même des on s'est fait et
julien on se fait des soirées alpes
julien oui mais quand même tu me même
invité à des vendanges donc forcément là
on est obligé d'y venir même est encore
jeune mais j'ai bien d'accord ok ballon
sous la coque est d'accord julien pas un
poids plus très longtemps quand même
même la tête du mal à dire va te faire
cuire un oeuf sur le plat
oui ah oui parce qu'ils ont bien deux
sites aime pas ça tu aimes pas ça voilà
c'est quoi le pire
manger des vers de terre ou manger ses
crottes de nez
déjà les crottes de nez c'est très bon
et c'est certainement très sage et vers
de terreaux jusque très bon c'est le
même rapport protéines graisses que la
volaille des bons petits spaghetti de
poulet comment tu expliques que 91% des
gens déclarent se curer le nez
si c'est pas pour le plaisir du petit
snack qui va avec mais tous les
archéologues ne mange pas leur pépite
il y en a qui font de la pâte à modeler
il y en a même qui jouent aux billes un
jour un concert ça j'ai été surpris vous
étiez au piano et vous avez dit tiens je
vais vous chanter une chanson sur les
règles parce que je suis au deuxième
jour des miennes mais la chose jour 3
c'est vrai nom mais sait il est vraiment
à bien peu de lire ça il est vraiment
tabou ça concerne quand même la moitié
de l'humanité on en parle encore comme
si c'était quelque chose de secret 2000
carrière en salles fin c'est pas normal
quoi oubliez moi ça tourne ça lui loupé
on est en 2021 il est temps que les
règles ce soit quelque chose de
complètement acquis et que ce constant
salaires d'abord fait moi aussi j'ai mes
règles très bien écouter
alors ça c'est dans le ventre de qui ça
n'a l'air de rien mais ce que nous
entendons c'est le tout premier sont
venus d'une autre planète
c'est la banque qui a été capté par l'un
des deux micros de persévérance le rover
de la nasa qui s'est posé sur mars le 22
février dernier
est ce que l'on entend c'est un vent
martien alors c'est aussi l'occasion il
connaît levante rien je supprime
beaucoup vous est unanime le chou ça
donne des gaz
un sujet un peu tabou que nous allons
donc aborder
émet en moyenne 14 p par jour donc ça
c'est classique alors il ya certains
paix qui viennent de l'air que vous
allez ingéré du coup quand vous allez
manger puis il ya d'autres gaz qui sont
eux le résultat du métabolisme la
fermentation coliques par les bakiev
on a beaucoup parlé de mars cette
semaine mais la lune reste un endroit
hyper convivial
ouais c'est un photomontage l'un des
nombreux clichés en compétition pour la
meilleure photo de l'année en même temps
un barbecue sur la lune c'est aussi
improbable actuellement une soirée entre
amis sur terre